là c'est les glaciers de scories de de
l'ancienne usine de l'Escalette donc en
fait c'est des déchets solides ils sont
très chargés en plomb et en arsenic on
voit d'ailleurs il y a pas de plantes
qui poussent dessus donc on a des sols
qui sont extrêmement pauvres extrêmement
contaminés si on peut appeler ça des
sols vraiment
[Musique]
depuis 10 ans le littoral au sud de la
métropole de Marseille est intégré dans
le Parc national des Calanques une
manière de préserver un écrin de nature
et des paysages emblématiques aux portes
de l'agglomération
au 19e et 20e siècle pourtant les
calanques de Marseille étaient occupés
par de nombreux usines avant d'être
classées ce littoral rocailleux est très
découpé au frais des conditions idéales
pour l'implantation d'industrie
métallurgiques et chimiques et beaucoup
d'entre elles ont durablement pollué cet
environnement aujourd'hui très fréquenté
ces pollutions invisibles à l'oeil nu
continuent en réalité à empoisonner une
partie des sols des Calanques
[Musique]
l'héritage industriel de toutes ces
usines vestiges archéologiques
d'ancêtres pourtant pas si lointain pose
beaucoup de questions et c'est grâce à
la complémentarité de différents champs
de recherche comme l'histoire la
géologie la chimie et la botanique qu'on
peut espérer trouver des solutions nous
visitons les lieux avec Loren tosini qui
est doctorante en écologie à
Aix-Marseille Université elle étudie la
végétation du parc national des
Calanques et leur capacités à piéger les
pollutions métalliques du sol ce qu'on
appelle la phyto remédiation donc tout
avec les pierres du site tout à la main
avec les pierres du site sans retourner
le sol
et ensuite on a planté
8 espèces là dessus voilà donc le but
c'est que ça soit vraiment intégré dans
le paysage en fait au final vous pouvez
d'ailleurs avoir un aperçu de son
travail grâce à l'application labo tour
développer par Aix-Marseille Université
et qui vous immerge à 360 degrés dans
les environnements de recherche des
scientifiques mais avant cela il faut
revenir sur l'histoire de ces pollutions
Marseille est spécialisé depuis
longtemps dans la production de savon au
début du 19e siècle toutefois les
guerres napoléoniennes empêchent
l'approvisionnement en soude végétale
qui en est l'un des ingrédients de base
il faut désormais en fabriquer à partir
de sels marins et d'acide sulfurique
c'est ce qu'on nomme le procédé Leblanc
or à l'époque les usines rejettent
directement dans l'air le résultat de
cette fabrication des effluves saturés
d'acide chlorhydrique qui attaquent les
poumons et ronge même les tuiles des
toises environnants des 1809 le maire de
Marseille sont inquiète auprès de la
Société de Médecine de la ville qui
recommande d'installer les usines soit à
au moins 1 km des habitations soit dans
une zone avec un relief important qui
bloquera les fumées soit là où les vents
dominants pousseront les fumées vers la
mer
les calanques répondent aux trois
critères en même temps
à quelques kilomètres de la ville qui
leur fournissaient de la main d'oeuvre
les usines étaient suffisamment
éloignées pour ne pas gêner les
habitants avec les fumées installez au
fond des Calanques elle profitait aussi
du Mistral qui emportait au large les
vapeurs polluées mais elles avaient
surtout un accès direct à la mer
permettant d'importer et d'exporter
facilement
c'est ainsi que de nombreuses usines de
transformation de soufre de verre de
plomb de pétrole ou encore de soude pour
le fameux savon de Marseille ont vu le
jour mais rapidement les dégâts
apparaissent les ouvriers en sont les
premières victimes baignant dans les
vapeurs d'acide chlorhydrique ou de
plombs toute la journée ils perdent
leurs dents le goût et l'odorat parfois
la vue sans parler de leur maladies
respiratoires intestinales et nerveuses
résident à proximité immédiate de
l'usine ils inhalent les pollutions en
permanence dans l'air mais aussi dans
l'eau et la nourriture mais souvent
d'origine étrangère en particulier
d'Italie ces jeunes hommes intéressent
peu les autorités
la contestation vient surtout des
riverains et en particulier des notables
marseillais qui constatent les dommages
sur leur bastide leur résidence
secondaire nichées dans le massif des
calanques
les odeurs nauséesabondent de soufre les
pierres noircies et l'atmosphère
toxiques les importunes la flore aussi
subit des dégradations considérables les
arbres meurent les herbes sont brûlés et
les éleveurs doivent cesser leur
activité faute de pâturage berger et
riverains attaque donc les industriels
en justice
et ça marche très vite en ce début du
19e siècle les industriels sont
condamnés à payer d'importantes sommes
pour dédommager les habitants des
Calanques un vrai bras de fer s'engage
mais l’état intervient à la capitale on
craint qu'à terme ces condamnations
fassent fermer toutes ces usines
chimiques qui sont jugées vitales l'état
pousse donc les industriels à agir pour
rendre leurs activités moins nocives et
échappées au procès
les propriétaires d'usine sont donc
bâtir de longues cheminées rampantes
pour rejeter les fumées au sommet des
collines et plus à proximité des
habitations le tout nouveau conseil de
salubrité marseillais valide le
dispositif et le préfet des sites que
les usines équipées de tels cheminées
rampantes ne pourront plus être attaqués
en justice
pourtant les pollutions subsistent
l'exemple de l'Escalette où nous nous
troublons aujourd'hui permet de s'en
rendre compte spécialisé dans la
production de plombs cette usine
s'installe en 1851 et fonctionne
jusqu'en 1924 c'est la seule qui survit
à la crise du plomb dans les années 1880
elle produit du plomb à partir de
minerais qui contiennent aussi de
l'argent il faut donc séparer les deux
métaux par une série de refroidissement
successifs ou avec l'aide de zinc ce qui
provoque des rejets très polluants au
total on peut estimer qu'entre 4 et 6%
du plomb produit par l'usine était
répandue dans l'atmosphère soit plus de
50 tonnes par an dès sa fondation
l'usine est bien équipée d'une cheminée
rampante de 300 mètres mais les fumées
sont juste rejetées un peu plus loin et
non perdu que quelque part particules en
chemin accrochés sur les pierres
calcaires du conduit le reste se répand
dans les environs
attenant à l'usine le propriétaire fait
aussi l'acquisition d'un crassier c'est
à dire d'un terrain utilisé pour déposer
les scories de plomb et tous les rejets
de fabrication
au total en 71 ans d'exploitation ce
sont 20 000 mètres cubes de scories qui
sont déposés et qui continue de polluer
les sols par érosion
par ailleurs une grande partie des
rejets chimiques sont directement versés
dans le port et ont causé une importante
destruction de l'écosystème marin
on le voit les mesures prises par les
autorités au 19e siècle sont très
favorables aux industriels et leur
permettent de polluer librement
l'environnement à condition de ne pas
enfumer directement les habitations à
proximité en l'absence d'appareil de
mesure on se base uniquement sur l'odeur
des fumées et on fixe un seuil limite de
manière très approximative toutes les
pollutions sans odeur ne sont pas pris
en compte la prise de conscience
environnementaliste est en réalité bien
plus tardive on dirait pas comme ça
après les usines dessous ça a moins
laissé de métaux dans le sol c'était
surtout des vapeurs en fait quand on
fait une carto mais ça aussi on a dans
le livre on voit vraiment que le point
rouge de la contamination en fait il
part d'ici
au début du 20e siècle au-delà des
dommages sur les maisons secondaires ou
les champs c'est la destruction de la
beauté naturelle des Calanques qu'on
déplore
en 1910 une grande manifestation a lieu
dans la calanque de Port-Miou à
l'initiative de la Société Nautique
marseillaise qui s'inquiète de la
dégradation du paysage par les usines et
les carrières par la suite des
associations locales se mobilisent et
obtiennent progressivement le classement
des Calanques comme des espaces protégés
mais au-delà des protestations se sont
surtout les fluctuations de l'économie
et la mondialisation qui ont fait fermer
les usines des Calanques le littoral de
Fos-sur-Mer a une quarantaine de
kilomètres bien plus adaptée pour
accueillir de grands navires à
logiquement attirer les industries il ne
reste plus aujourd'hui dans les
calanques que l'usine d'aluminium de
Gardanne avec ses fameux rejets de
bourge qui ont suscité de longues
mobilisations jusqu'à très récemment
[Musique]
si presque toutes les activités
industrielles sont désormais partie il
en reste néanmoins beaucoup de traces
les bâtiments d'abord un patrimoine
industriel abandonné à son sort ou
reconverti en habitation et en lieu
culturel mais il reste surtout des
traces de pollution scories de plomb des
pots d'Amiens fleurs locales endommagées
voilà un héritage bien plus
problématique
et c'est ce sur quoi travaillent les
écologues aujourd'hui Loren tosini qui
est doctorante à Aix-Marseille
Université et spécialiste de la gestion
par Phyto remédiation dont on a parlé en
introduction sur place on lui a demandé
quel était l'ampleur de la pollution à
l'Escalette comment cette pollution
était mesurée et surtout comment les
végétaux pouvaient-ils permettre de
réduire la pollution des sols
globalement il y a quand même une
méconnaissance de la pollution qui se
trouve dans les calanques quand les
industries métallurgiques ont commencé à
décliner dans les calanques donc au
cours du 20e siècle il y a eu vraiment
un changement de perception donc il
s'est fait dans le temps c'est à dire
que c'était un endroit de relégation des
industries et c'est devenu au fil du
temps un espace de nature et de loisirs
donc c'est vrai que on a un peu oublié
finalement tout ce qui s'est passé même
si on peut encore le voir dans le
paysage et ben dans le sol donc en
général les gens sont un peu étonnés ils
se disent mais c'est un parc national et
il y a de la pollution dans dans sur
cette zone donc c'est vraiment ça qui
est hyper particulier ici c'est le c'est
le premier parc pérusain de France en
fait et ensuite les gens sont souvent
étonnés ils disent ah oui mais c'est
très pollué mais il y a quand même des
plantes qui poussent dessus mais comment
elles font il y a une invisibilisation
en fait de la pollution par le fait que
cette végétation finalement elle est
tolérante donc elle arrive à repartir
mais il faut pas c'est pas parce qu'il y
a de végétation que la pollution
n'existe plus en fait les pollutions
persistent aujourd'hui en particulier
dans le milieu marin les eaux traités
par la station d'épuration de Marseille
sont rejetées au cœur du parc national
dans la calanque de cortiaux elle montre
de fortes concentrations de molécules
pharmaceutiques de pesticides et de
détergent qui persiste dans
l'environnement lors des orages le
lessivage des sols entraîne vers la mer
les pollutions métalliques et chimiques
des anciennes usines et la roche
calcaire avec ses nombreuses fissures
favorisent leur passage vers les nappes
phréatiques à la pollution elle est très
importante et très étendue et elle est
persistante dans le sol les métaux ça se
dégrade pas donc elle va rester dans le
sol donc il fallait trouver une solution
de gestion pour confiner en fait cette
pollution donc là on peut lui utiliser
des ce qu'on appelle des solutions
fondées sur la nature et donc on utilise
des plantes natives et le but c'est en
fait qu'elle confine la pollution avec
leurs racines et en association aussi
avec les organisme du sol qui vont les
aider à confiner cette pollution et
ensuite on a des actions plus
biochimiques ça veut dire que les
plantes elles sont capables de sécréter
des des molécules chimiques qui sont des
sortes de colle à métaux donc ils vont
donc coller ces métaux dans le sol et
être capable aussi dans séquestrer une
partie dans leur racine grâce au lycée
agricole des Calanques les chercheurs
d'Aix-Marseille Université ont pu créer
une pépinière de plantes natives des
calanques et adaptées aux conditions
environnementales locales ce sont elles
qui sont plantées sur les zones polluées
c'est très important d'utiliser des
espèces natives locales d'ici parce que
déjà il faut utiliser des espèces qui
soient adaptées au stress ou
environnementaux intrinsèque au milieu
faut des plantes qui résistent au sol
pauvres qui résistent au vent qui
résiste à la sécheresse et ensuite il
fallait aussi des plantes qui tolèrent
la présence de métaux du sol et il se
trouve que les plantes
méditerranéennes sont de bonnes
candidates en fait
pour tolérer ces métaux dans le sol il y
a une espèce qui est hyper emblématique
des Calanques il y a 96% de sa
population ici c'est la stragale de
Marseille les coussins de belle-mère et
cette plante donc c'est une plante qui
est menacée et qui est protégé et tout
quasiment toute la population dans les
et dans les calanques elle a subit plein
de pressions anthropique etc et il s'est
trouvé que cette plante se développait
assez bien sur les sols contaminés en
fait si on ne répare jamais complètement
un environnement pollué et s'il est
difficile de sensibiliser les
populations sur ce littoral extrêmement
fréquentées on le voit des remèdes
existent grâce à l'interdisciplinarité
entre les sciences de la nature et les
sciences humaines il est possible de
réhabiliter les espaces et de gérer les
contaminations pour conserver la
biodiversité
ce sont l'histoire la géographie la
chimie et l'écologie ensemble qui
permettent de mieux comprendre ces
problématiques et aujourd'hui d'imaginer
des solutions durables fondées sur la
nature et ses capacités de résilience
merci à Lauren tocini de nous avoir
guidés sur le terrain pouvait
télécharger l'application labo tour si
vous souhaitez en savoir plus sur les
recherches menées ici dans les calanques
de Marseille et vous pourrez aussi
découvrir les travaux d'autres
chercheuses merci à Aix-Marseille
Université et à playazure pour avoir
permis la réalisation de cette vidéo qui
je l'espère vous a plu je vous dis à
bientôt et n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
[Musique]
aussi
on en avait plus pas Chanel blue et la
Chine en faisant
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut même se baigner
sérieusement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]